you
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us for the
and final presentation of our butyl
ecology series today's live broadcast
advancing precision immunotherapy
through next-generation sequencing of
t-cell receptors part 2 on combine TCR
beta s our assay is presented by dr.
timothy Looney staff scientists
bioinformatics thermo Fisher last month
dr. Looney highlighted novel
applications of long amplicon TCR beta
TCR be sequencing today we introduce a
newly launched short term excuse me
short amplicon TCR be sequencing assay
design to interrogate the TCR be CDR 3
region from fresh or formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded FFPE samples
I am Alexis Clouse of laberd's and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information on our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher calm now let's get started
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab sound at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the answer a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
presentation is educational as the
software continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right and
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I'd like
to now introduce our presenter dr.
Timothy Looney
dr. Looney is an accomplished
computational biologist and an
immunologist
with expertise and methods and
applications of B and T cell receptor
sequencing including biomarker discovery
and assay development he is currently a
SAS scientist and informatics read for
repertoire sequencing with a clinical
sequencing division at Thermo Fisher
Scientific dr. Lenny's interests and
specialties are centered around
repertoire analysis for Mito ecology
autoimmunity and infectious disease
translational research for complete
biography on doctor Lamine please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. looney you may now begin your
presentation great thank you thank you
for that nice introduction
it's a pleasure to be here to talk to
you about our new TCR beta short Reed SR
sequencing assay and to get started I I
want to give you an outline of the
slides that I will present I'll start by
giving a brief introduction to TCR
sequencing and the SR acid design after
which will switch to applications of the
TCR B SR assay which include
interrogation of FFP preserved samples
and detection and tracking of rare
clones for longitudinal analysis of
clones of interest and then in the third
section we will explore data addressing
t-cell repertoire features of chronic
cytomegalovirus infection I think you'll
you'll find this interesting so to get
started I want to remind everyone that
our TCR sequencing assays are part of a
broad portfolio of assays aims to help
you with your on ecology research needs
and within the immuno oncology solutions
we provide there are four asses the
uncle mind immune response reaches
research acid which is a targeted gene
expression profiling assay designed for
interrogation of the tumor
microenvironment
the uncle mine TCR beta LRS a long read
this is what we discussed in the
previous webinar and this is a wonderful
asset for interrogating peripheral blood
the SR assay as I mentioned is the focus
of this webinar and then the uncle mine
tumor mutation load assay is designed
for in quantifying tumour mutation from
sequencing of tumor
and I'll mention that the strategy in
the choice of these four acids is tasked
with interrogating all aspects of the
timber immune interactions that are part
of the cancer immunity cycle so this
ranges from profiling of tumor needle
antigens through the uncle mine tumor
mutation load an assay within the
peripheral blood detecting t-cell
signatures of response to tumor neo
antigen to the uncle mine TCR beta L our
assay and then within the tumor
microenvironment use of the TCR beta s
our assay and the immune response
research assay which are both compatible
with FFPE preserved material
and these assays we believe help to
address to two critical questions in
immuno oncology first what are
predictive biomarkers for adverse events
during immunotherapy and are there
biomarkers for response to immunotherapy
and for both of these questions we
believe that TCR sequencing plays an
important role
we discussed this less in the previous
webinar and I think I'm going to
elaborate on that point within the
coming slides so now just to the
background of the TCR sequencing and the
T cell receptor biology the t-cell
receptor is a heterodimer consisting of
an alpha chain and a beta chain we focus
on sequencing the beta chain which is
far more diverse in sequence base and in
some respects than more informative the
the beta chain is produced by vdj
recombination where tandem li arranged
variable diversity and joining genes
recombined to produce a functional
receptor the interface of the vdj forms
the CDR 3 sequence which is incredibly
diverse owing to the combinatorial
nature of that process but also the
action of extra nucleotide to back at
the ends of the vgj and the addition of
non templated bases by or also called n
additions by T DT so the CBR 3 is so
diverse that it can serve as a natural
barcode to track T cells over time and
measure T cell receptor diversity with
that said the CDR 1 and 2 are also
important in determining the answers and
specificity of the receptor and we
discussed how the TCR beta LR acid could
be used to profile polymorphism within
the CDR 1 & 2
so now I want to turn to the acid design
and this cartoon shows the design of the
L R and s are assays to help you compare
the two the ldlr assay utilizes primers
targeting the framework one region of
the variable gene and the constant gene
region and this creates an amplicon
spanning all three CDR regions to enable
sequencing of the variable the germline
encoded variable gene as well as the CDR
3 and as mentioned in our previous
webinar this allows one to interrogate
variable gene polymorphism which may be
a predictive biomarkers for adverse
events during immunotherapy now owing to
the long amplicon design the LLR assay
is not compatible with with FFP
preserved materials and this is where
the srs a plays a complementary role
it's a short amplicon design targeting
the framework 3 region and the joining
gene region of the rearranged receptor
this the amplicon spans the CDR 3 region
which is the crucial region for tracking
T cell clones and measuring diversity
and owing to the short amplicon length
it is compatible with FFP preserved
material both DNA and RNA
and for reasons that I'll elaborate on
in the coming slides the SRS a is also a
great tool for tracking and detection of
very rare clones and that owes in part
to the types of sequencing chips that
one can use with the SRS a so to prep to
provide you a little bit more detail on
this I want to remind everyone that
these assays are designed for the gene
studio s5 series of which there are
three models that differ in their the
hardware that is used to process the
sequencing data so there's a there's a
difference in the turnaround time and
through prepare day but the other aspect
that is important to consider is that
with the s5 series one can use different
sequencing chips to obtain different
levels of throughput so going from the
510 chip which has two to three million
reads output up to the 550 chip where
one can obtain up to 130 million reads
and there are differences in terms of
the read output but also the supported
read lengths so you'll note that the 520
and 530 chips for example support the
longest read length and these are really
the ideal for the LR assay which has a
long amplicon now the SRS a owing to its
short amplicon can be used with all of
these chips so this is where the
detection of rare clones comes into play
one can use the highest capacity
sequencing chips to obtain very high
sequencing coverage of libraries to
detect rare clones
both assays are designs with the
philosophy that user hands-on time
should be minimal and there should be an
end-to-end solution
these are ampliseq protocols with less
than 30 minutes hands-on time you set it
up and and walk away the sequencing is
very fast and there's a end-to-end
bioinformatics solution on Io reporter
and so the total turnaround time sample
to answer is approximately 48 hours
now with respect to the analysis there's
a rich informatics suite that we have
developed on ion reporter which is a
cloud or or server based analysis
platform this allows one to do things
like obtain the sequence and frequency
of clones within a sample but also
obtain secondary repertoire features
such as t-cell measurements of t-cell
expansion or diversity and readouts of
the variable gene usage within a
repertoire I'll also note that the
software allows for longitudinal
analysis clones so tracking clones
across multiple samples so this makes it
really nice for evaluating the frequency
of a clone of interest in an ax type of
longitudinal experiment
so before showing you data for the SRS a
I want to put everything in perspective
and in this table I highlight this the
strengths of both the LR and SRS a so
you can get a sense of when you might
want to use one versus the other firstly
with input type as I mentioned the LR
assay is designed for non FFP RNA and
it's really the ideal assay for
interrogation of peripheral 1 the SR
asset can be used with RNA genomic DNA
and even cell free DNA and it's FFPE
compatible and this is in part owing to
the short amplicon length of the assay
with respect to the sample bar coding
system the LRS a employs the iron select
barcodes while the TCR beta s our assay
utilizes a novel ion dual bar coding
system which I'll talk about in the
coming slides and this is this bar code
system has been designed to help improve
the performance of applications where
one wants to detect very rare clones and
sequence libraries to very high def
with respect to polymorphism and
haplotype analysis of the t-cell
receptor beta locus this is an
application that's uniquely enabled by
the LR assay and that's owing to the
DeLong amplicon covering the term line
encoded portion of variable gene
now TCR convergence this is an
interesting repertoire feature that that
may have biomarker utility over a range
of applications this can be evaluated
with both the L R and s RSA owing to the
fact that it relies on analysis of the
CDR three region
in terms of assessing t-cell expansion
this is also known as as repertoire
evenness or clone allottee those that
that feature of the repertoire can be
evaluated with both assays equally well
now that as I mentioned ffs be preserved
samples that's that's the ideal sample
type for the SR assay and detection and
tracking are very rare clones the SR
assay has the advantage owing to the the
use the compatibility with our highest
capacity chips
so now switching to some data
highlighting applications of the SRS a
I'm going to start with looking at FFP
preserved samples and then we're going
to switch to looking at detection of
very rare clones
so this slide highlights an experiment
to analyze t-cells within an FFP
preserved tonsil specimen and in this
experiment RNA was extracted from the
FFP preserved tonsil to obtain a pool of
RNA of which twenty five nanograms was
used to prepare a live one library and
then a separate twenty five nanograms to
prepare a second library and I'm
highlighting some high-level repertoire
features from that analysis the clones
detected the diversity of the of the
other repertoire and then the evenness
which is a measure of t-cell expansion
higher even closer to one indicates that
there are few expands clones while a low
even it indicates that there are one or
several highly expanded clones in the
sample and you'll note that replicate
one and two are quite similar in terms
of the readouts of the diversity and
evenness and this is really what you
would expect when sequencing material
from the same RNA pool the other thing
that one would expect is clonal overlap
between the between these samples given
that they're derived from the same
starting material and indeed on the
right you'll note that this plot
highlighting the frequency of clones and
the distribution among the two samples
that there's a significant fraction of
those clones that are shared across the
two libraries
so that was the FFPE RNA here's an
example from SF de DNA and in this
example biopsies were obtained from an
individual with colorectal cancer cancer
either from lymph node a primary tumor
and a liver metastasis so you'll note
first that the lymph node sample
revealed a greater number of clones than
the primary tumor and liver metastasis
that may be expected based on the
biology of the lymph node and the fact
that it may accumulate t-cells the other
thing that I think is interesting from
this analysis is that you will note that
there are clones that are found both in
the primary tumor and the metastasis and
on the scatter plot on the right will
note 34 shared clones so these shared
clones may be at a higher likelihood of
being tumor antigen specific given that
they're both infiltrating a tumor and
that these tumors are at different parts
of the body so this is the type of
hypothesis that could be evaluated with
downstream studies and it highlights the
fact that this asset can can function
well with a small amount of FFP deep
reserved material
now with respect to FFPE experiments
it's also critical to have a method for
evaluating the quality of the sample
because in some cases the F the FFPE
treatments or the age of the sample will
make the sample too degraded to the
function and so that the molecular
biology team has done a great job in
developing assays that allow users to to
readily evaluate the quality of the FFPE
RNA or DNA and here I'm highlighting the
this cd3 quantification assay which uses
a qPCR of the CD 247 gene that's part of
the t-cell receptor signaling complex
and running this assay on your FFPE
preserved but materials can allow one to
get a sense of whether that the material
will has the possibility of being used
for successful library preparation so
that's for RNA FFP RNA there's also an
assay for qualifying effort FFPE
preserve DNA samples via the RNA HPSA
and the protocols for using these assays
are described in the user guide so I
think that's a really nice resource for
for users of this assay
now to MRD and or more broadly detection
and tracking of rare t-cell clones this
this approach utilizes the fact that the
cv r3 is incredibly diverse and it's so
diverse that it can be used as a natural
barcode to track a clone of interest and
one of the this is actually one of the
one of the first applications of NGS
based repertoire sequencing because
using this type of approach one can
readily detect very rare clones that
would otherwise be impossible detect by
standard approaches like flow cytometry
and the SR assay is really nice for this
partly because of the the ability to
generate large libraries and sequence
into great depth using the ion series
chips so just to give it give you a
sense of how this works typically one
will sequence T cells or B cells at a
time point where the the malignancy is
at a high frequency and by sequencing
one will detect a dominant clone and
that clone will have a CDR 3 sequence
which can then be used to track the
frequency of that malignancy
longitudinally after a treatment has
been provided so after treatments one
asks what is the frequency of the mode
of that malignant clone and if the
treatment is very effective the most the
malignity may end up being at a very low
frequency or even undetectable
so by sequencing one can search for very
rare clones and thus get a sense of
whether the malignancy is truly gone or
if it's really it's actually at a low
level but may return and there is still
some question in the field what what is
the limit of detection necessary to
determine whether someone is actually
actually has a complete response in
terms of this minimal residual disease
or along that line and you know some
people say one in 10,000 while others
it's possible that actually one in a
hundred thousand or even 1 million may
be the most appropriate so if one wants
to detect very rare clones one half the
sequence the great depth and produce
large libraries and this this type of
application makes the phenomena of
barcode bleed through more more of an
issue and this refers to the the the
phenomena where sequences from one
sample in a multiplex sequencing run
will appear in unrelated samples that
are sequence on the same chip or even in
consecutive runs so in this in this
cartoon example you can imagine a t-cell
malignancy clone example one could
theoretically appear at a low low
frequency in sample 2 3 4 or even
samples in the in a consecutive run and
this is something that you that one
really would like to avoid in in these
types of advocate applications because
it can potentially confound the
interpretation of the results and so
with this in mind we developed a novel
ion dual bar coding kit which which
greatly reduces this phenomenon and the
barcode kit utilizes two sets of bar
code sequences one at the one at the
start of the read and one at the end of
the read and this this combination of
barcodes allows one to to greatly
diminish the frequency of these these
bleeds or events
and as an example I'm going to show you
in this slide an experiment that we
performed to test the efficacy of these
of this dual bar building system to
eliminate bleed through
in this experiment we created five TCR
beta sequencing libraries one that's a
mixture of jurkat and peripheral blood
leukocytes cDNA so there's a single
dominating clone within the jerk at TBL
library and then four additional
libraries that are created from
peripheral blood leukocytes cDNA and
dust don't have the dirt at clone and we
ask when we sequence these and multiplex
do we find that jurkat sequence in any
of the libraries on the same chip and at
the bottom you'll note the results of
two separate experiments where we find
that even in cases where the dirt a
clone is at very high frequency in one
library it's not found in the other
libraries so this really is a testament
to the the value of this dual bar coding
system for detection and tracking of
rare clones now the other aspect of
tracking rare clones that I want to
bring up is the necessity for
construction of large libraries one
needs to construct a large library to
increase the chances of detecting a rare
clone and I just want to bring up the
fact that when one is preparing
libraries from RNA as opposed to DNA
it's easier to create a very large
library only to the fact that the RNA is
already enriched for your target of
interest the t-cell receptor so in this
experiment this is this is a table taken
from the user guide where we prepared a
series of libraries from increasing
amounts of CD and cDNA derived from
peripheral blood leukocytes 10 nanograms
up to one microgram
and these libraries were sequenced to a
very high sequencing depth 30 30 million
reads and then reads were randomly down
sampled
the table is showing you the number of
clones detected so what what you can
take from this is that by increasing the
input amount of cDNA one can create very
large libraries now for most use cases
we recommend twenty five nanograms of
cDNA to derive from PVL total RNA and
sequencing to about 1.5 million read
step and you'll note some of the cells
in this table are bull are bolded this
is this is really indicating the point
of inflection in the library sequencing
where one begins to approach saturation
and so this is this is kind of a general
guidance as to the best point in terms
of input amount and sequencing depth to
maximize the number of clones detected
so now I'm going to switch to the third
section of this talk t-cell repertoire
features of chronic cytomegalovirus
infection and I want to start by
describing the biology of federal
Megillah virus cytomegalovirus is a
common and chronic viral infection in
some countries greater than 95 percent
of the individuals are CMV
cytomegalovirus infection positive and
in the US for example approximately 50
percent of the population has test
positive for cytomegalovirus this is
chronic in that it's believed that once
one is infected with cytomegalovirus the
infection is never completely eradicated
so it's really a master at immune
evasion and for that reason firstly the
fact that it's very common secondly that
one can readily obtained samples from
individuals of known CMV status from
blood centers and third that this de
cytomegalovirus has really exquisite
mechanisms of the knee invasion it's a
really interesting virus to study and
you know immune evasion viral immune
evasion may be related or at least
provide insight into mechanisms of
immune evasion by cancer so you know
other aspects of CNBC's EMV biology that
are of interest it can infect a broad
range of cell types including epithelial
cells which are common cancer cell type
and also lymphocytes so even t-cells can
be infected by cytomegalovirus to some
extent
one of the at one of the ways in which
CMV is thought to evade the immune
system is through the generation of CMV
reactive T regulatory cells I bring this
up because it's also thought that T
regulatory cells may play a role in
cancer immune evasion and then you know
another interesting point mentioned in
the literature is that CMV infection is
associated with large T cell phone
alliterations particularly in the
elderly and the bottom right of this
slide I'm highlighting a figure from a
paper looking at CMV reactive T cells in
elderly and you'll note the percentage
indicating the fraction of cells that
were estimated to be CMV reactive so
it's really it can be a very profound
impact that this virus can have on the
repertoire so so with these points it
seems reasonable that that one might be
able to identify T cell repertoire
features of cytomegalovirus infection
and to do this we took a look we we
generated data and also generate a
compare to our data to data that was
already present in the in the in the
public domain so in the coming slides
I'm going to show you data from three
data sets data set one is generated
using the online TCR beta s RFA using
peripheral blood leukocyte total RNA as
the input C DNA from that total RNA and
sequenced on the gene Studio s five five
thirty chip to approximately 1.5 million
reads depth and this this cDNA was
obtained from thirty-five individuals of
known CMV status obtained from the
Stanford Blood Center and this is a it's
a really easy way to obtain samples of
known CMV status you can purchase a
sample from the Blood Center and for a
small fee you can obtain the CMV status
event of that sample
now data set 2 is produced using the on
combine TCR beta l our assay using the
same set of 35 individuals again using
cDNA derive from total RNA and again
sequenced on the s5 via the 530 chip and
targeting 1.5 million reads depth per
library and the third data set is an
amino seek data set from from literature
this it's a quite large data set
consisting of t-cell repertoires from
761 individuals of known CMV status and
this was published in Emerson and all
2017 Nature Genetics and this is using G
DNA from peripheral blood leukocytes and
this is sequence using the Illumina
HiSeq
so given what I told you about T cell
biology one could ask whether or not
there are differences in T cell
expansion as a function of CMV status
and here I'm showing the highlighting an
illustration of T cell evenness and even
this is a measure of clonal expansion
the lower the evenness the the greater
the the number of T cells that are
expanded and even this is just one minus
the clone allottee if you're using
immuno seek and it's also known as the
normalized Shannon entropy so we wanted
to know whether even is differed as a
function of CMV status and here's you'll
note the results for the TCR beta s are
LR and the immunity data set and so
you'll take a look at the left and the
color indicates the CMV status and
you'll note it's a pretty striking
observation that there's a there's a
significant difference in TCR evenness
as a function of CMV status can be
positive individuals have a lower
evenness indicating that they tend to
have larger clones expanded clones and
this is true across the three data sets
it seems to be a very consistent trend
and you'll note on the right that this
trend is so strong that one can actually
predict with good accuracy the CMV
status
exclusively using the evenness of the
rapid VARs and and you'll note on these
these plots the AUC this is the area
under the curve the higher the number
the closer to one the more accurate or
the better the predictor and so you'll
note that all that the three assays do a
good job of discriminating C and B
positive and negative based on even the
status
now I wanted to get just a pause and to
discuss the significance of this result
because I I think it's important for a
number of reasons firstly when we talk
about T cell receptor evenness as a
predictive biomarker for immunotherapy
response you know for example sequencing
a repertoire baseline before someone
receives to check one blockade and then
predicting based on that value whether
an individual responds this data
suggests that the CMV status has a large
impact on evenness thus if one wants to
use evenness as a predictive biomarkers
one may need to take into account the
CMV status of an individual otherwise
this the effect of the CMV infection may
may obfuscate differences only to t-cell
responses to tumor
and you know to my to my knowledge from
the literature that hasn't been done and
so that's something that I think we can
all think about as looking at CMV status
and evenness in evaluating the
predictive utility of that biomarker now
the second aspect is the DNA versus RNA
issue you know one one kind of
continuing debate in the repertoire
field is what are the advantages or
disadvantages of RNA versus DNA and
you'll note that that the TCR beta s R
and L are assays here were used on you
uh with RNA template while the immunity
was used with DNA template and they both
produce equivalent results essentially
equivalent so this really emphasizes the
notion that RNA can provide a great
readout of the repertoire you know at
least as good if not better than than
DNA based analyses
other thing to note it may be evident
from the Collette graph I just showed
you but there's a very high correlation
evenness values between the TCR beta SR
and LR assays so irrespective of the
apps you use you know you can be
confident that you're getting an
evenness value that is that is that is
really measuring the biology of those
samples
and then the other point I want to
mention you know there's some discussion
in the literature about whether the
t-cell repertoire ages or there's some
kind of loss of diversity as a function
of age and in these plots you'll note on
the the x-axis indicates the age of the
donor and the y-axis indicates the
evenness and the coloring indicates the
CMV status and and the lines indicate
the best fit for the respective
categories so you'll note that with age
it looks as though in both datasets
there tends to be a decrease in evenness
so greater propensity towards expanded
clones in the elderly and that's that
really that's really consistent with
literature the other point is the that
in CMV positive individuals it seems
that there's a that this trend is more
pronounced so if want to see and be
positive there is a greater tendency
towards large clonal proliferation and
again this is this really fits well with
what is known in the literature about
about CMV now I want to turn to
convergence in our previous webinar we
discussed the utility of convergence
within the immuno oncology setting and
the idea is that chronic antigen
stimulation may give rise to t-cell
receptors which have a stereotyped amino
acid sequence and convergent tt-rs are
those which are identical in amino acid
space but different in nucleotide space
and this this this fact indicates that T
cells independently went through vdj
recombination and proliferated in
response to some antigen stimulation and
the one exciting aspect of convergence
is that it may preferentially arise
owing to chronic antigen stimulation and
you know we discussed convergence in in
the context of cancer neo antigens but
one could also imagine that
Virgen t-cell responses might might
arise following chronic responses to
viral antigen
and just as
at an example to remind everyone
is an example of three clones which make
up a convergent group they're identical
and amino-acid space but different in
nucleotide space we have the same
variable gene the same same CDR three
amino acid sequence but they're
different within the CG are three
nucleotide sequences and they're at
they're different at the VD and deejay
junctions and you'll note that based on
the coloring of the the text and I want
to point out that
owing to the nature of convergence
substitution sequencing errors can
readily give rise to artifacts that
resemble convergent t-cell responses and
you can you can note that from the slide
and so it's something that this
measurement of this feature may be
particularly suited to ion torrent
sequencing which has a low level of
substitution sequencing errors and to
give you a better idea of why that may
be I just want to remind everyone of the
way in which client or sequencing occurs
there's templating of a molecule on a
bead which is placed into a cell that
contains a transistor and when that
template is amplified hydrogen ions are
released and this changes the pH of the
well and that change in pH can be sensed
and then translated into sequence so
this sequencing methodology is fast and
it uses sequential flow of nucleotides
so one flow at a time and that may be
one aspect of one reason why this
sequencer has a low substitution error
rate because the the sequencer really
just has to determine whether or not a
nucleotide incorporated not whether or
not a nucleotide nucleotide incorporated
and what equal tide incorporated so it's
kind of a simpler problem to solve in
some respects and here's an example of
the substitution error rates using that
F 5 30 chip and sequencing the e coli th
1b genome on the left you'll note the
types of errors following alignment of
those five 30 reads to the e coli genome
and they're broken down by the error
mode
substitution insertion deletion and
total so you'll note firstly that that
blue line the substitution sequencing
error is far lower than the others and
just to mention there's a little almost
like a blip at the very far left around
zero bases that that little uptick in
the error rate to my understanding is an
artifact deriving from the alignment
methodology so it's obvious that the you
know the error mode is dominated by
insertions and deletions and then moving
to the right you'll note that a
comparison of the substitution errors
for Illumina and and these error values
were taken from a recent paper Shermer
at al 2016 using 100 base pair reads and
then for the Ion Torrent and with the
Ion Torrent that value is calculated
using read base position 10 to 100
the plot on the left and just just a
note that the CD our three sequence
which is the critical part of the TCL t
cell receptor beta library sits at about
25 bases 25 to 60 so that's at a portion
of the read weather's extremely low
substitution arrows
and the other point to mention is that
in all of the substitution error values
on the right this is a combination of
substitution errors polling to PCR so
base incorporation errors and sequencing
errors so it's a combination of those
two
now it's a return to convergence we
talked about how convergence may be a
hallmark of chronic antigen stimulation
and we noted elevated convergence in
those who respond to checkpoint blockade
immunotherapy this was discussed in the
previous webinar so it's natural to ask
whether convergence is also elevated in
CMV positive individuals and just to
mention with this convergent TCR
frequency is calculated as the sum of
the frequency of clones that are
identical in amino acid space but
different in nucleotide space so a
variable gene plus CDR three amino acid
shared by two or more clones so applying
this definition to the three data sets
we note the following with respect to
convergence so I first want to talk
about the on combine TCR beta assays and
then I'll switch to discussing the
immuno seek you'll note that the
TCR beta s R and L are assays do show a
tendency towards higher convergence in
the CMV positive individuals suggesting
that a subset of the CMV positive
individuals may have this tendency
towards a response to chronic viral
antigen and to look at that a little bit
more closely I want to I want to bring
up the relationship of TCR evenness and
convergence because one thing you could
ask is whether or not evenness and
convergence are the same or whether
they're actually different features of
the repertoire and you'll note that even
this and convergence are non put not
correlated in the immuno seat data I'm
it's using India in the thermo Fisher
data in a scatter plot on the left with
the y-axis indicates TCR evenness and
x-axis indicates convergence and you'll
note that on the right convergence
values can independently predict gmv
status evenness values can predict GMB
status and a combination of convergence
plus evenness through a logistic
regression model can improve the
discrimination of CMV status
so now turning to the immuno immuno seek
data when we perform the same analysis
of that immunity data that the results
look look different there appear to be a
very strong correlation between the
evenness or carnality and convergence in
this plot you'll note the correlation of
negative 0.94 and you know one might ask
why why is this the case you know
hypothetically this what this
relationship is is saying is that the
greater the the this clone size in a
sample the greater the chance that one
will identify a large clone as a
converging clone
and that could be possible if there are
residual substitution errors within
within the data so errors arising from
the PCR or sequencing that are not
corrected that create artifacts
resembling convergent ecr's that that's
that the hypothesis
and to look at this a little bit more
closely we asked whether taking the
number of reads per clone within the
immunity data the length of the CD are
three per clone and
assuming some level of residual
substitution errors going from a high
level of residual subject substitution
error of 1 & 384 down to 1 and 80,000
for base pair and asking whether such
residual substitution error could give
rise to the type of data that the type
of values that we observe
and I mentioned one in 381 and 384
because from recent publications that
that is suggested as the raw error rate
of the Illumina HiSeq the the raw
substitution error and when taking these
factors into account and of course this
is a simple model but we noted that a
residual substitution error rate of 1 in
700 7500 could give rise to be observed
convergence values so you know taken at
face value this would suggest that the
the residual substitution error rate of
the immuno seek data is far lower than
the law substitution rates of the
Illumina platform but is still
significant and enough to to obfuscate
the differences in convergence that that
may exist between responders and
non-responders to immunotherapy or other
other conditions and that's you know
that's this is obviously an analysis
from a simple model and more insight to
be obtained by analysis of the raw data
so I want to finally put everything in
perspective with convergence because I
think I think it's it's a it's a pretty
exciting biomarker today we talked about
convergence response to viral antigen
and in the previous webinar we discussed
convergence in response to tumour Neil
antigen and tumour neo antigen can be
derived from nonsynonymous mutations
which are you know also interrogated by
tumour mutation version sequencing
they also may derive from aberrant post
translational modifications now these
are really interesting because they can
be highly immunogenic but they're not
detectable by sequencing a tumor so this
is an aspect of tumor immunogenicity
that one cannot detect through
sequencing a tumor and I think it's one
of the advantages of TCR convergence as
a potential biomarker and then finally
the final answering source to mention of
course autoantigens this convergence
could potentially arise in chronic
autoimmune disease of which there is
also an aberrant post translational
modification component in many cases
and then the the final piece of this
t-cell receptor beta variable gene pile
polymorphism we discussed in the
previous webinar how certain variable
gene alleles or sets of alleles also
known as haplotypes could modulate the
way in which T cells interact with HLA
potentially increasing the likelihood of
Auto antigen recognition
so - to some to summarize what I've what
I told you today I want to look back at
our webinar series in the first in the
first webinar we discussed how targeted
gene expression profiling - er mutation
burden analysis and TCR sequencing may
be combined to improve understanding of
the complex tumor immune cell
interactions in the second webinar I
described how the TCR beta L R assay may
allow for assessment of polymorphism and
convergence from peripheral blood to
enable prediction of adverse events and
immunotherapy response and then here I
discussed how interrogation of FFPE
preserved DNA or RNA may may be
accomplished with the SR assay which is
also great for detecting rare clones and
then the two key points from the
analysis of CMV first CMV infection
strongly shapes the repertoire and
researchers may need to take into
account the CMV status when interpreting
t-cell repertoire features as potential
predictor biome predictive biomarkers
and then the final points is the
sensitivity of TCR convergence
measurements to substitution errors and
this may be a way in which Ion Torrent
is a well suited to this task so finally
i want to i want to end by saying that i
believe that immune repertoire
sequencing and the understanding of this
data type is really just beginning and
so i am highly optimistic about the
future of this data type in terms of
immuno oncology biomarker research so
with that I'd like to finish the slide
deck and and of course take any
questions that the audience might have
you
you
are there any questions
I think you might be on loop I'm youth
by the way Alexis
I sincerely apologize about that you are
a hundred percent correct um thank you
dr. Looney for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer a question
box located on the far left your screen
it will answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is
can this assay be used to detect an
adverse immune response to IO treatments
great question the SRS a that I
presented today the short read a say
exclusively covers the CDR three region
so it's while it's but it's possible
that the CDR three regional loan could
be informed into adverse events what we
showed in our previous webinar was that
the LR assay which includes coverage of
the variable gene and polymorphism
within the variable gene may provide the
data that can be most useful for
prediction of adverse events and this is
through interrogation of polymorphism
excessively very next question could you
comment on DNA vers RNA for FFPE samples
the DNA RNA data in the presentation was
from PBL
yeah yeah so I hope I just I'm going to
bring back the slides because I I did
bring up some data using ffe preserved
samples hopefully you can see this you
know in general I would say if you have
the opportunity to use RNA I would use
RNA because one can more easily create
large libraries from a small amount of
material and then secondly the RNA
consists entirely of productive
rearrangements so those that are coding
for a t-cell receptor that is ultimately
expressed and for that reason one has in
some aspects more efficient sequencing
of the t-cell repertoire whereas from
DNA a fraction of the beads will
correspond to unproductive
rearrangements that are not expressed
could a cancer TCR be used for targeting
a CA RT cell
but a cancer TCR he used a t-cell cancer
specific TCR be used
targeting a puzzle
for it says for targeting a CA RT cell
oh great question can we use this text
and correctly it's can we use TCR
sequencing to monitor the activity of
therapeutic t-cells car t-cells and to
that yes you can all the only
requirement is that therapeutic t-cell
has in endogenous t-cell receptor that
can be amplified and sequenced in and
for that application T cell receptor
sequencing was really nice we are
getting so many great questions so let's
move on to our next one
are there standard TCR convergence
groups defined yet like for b-cell
receptor stereotyping
you know uh I I don't know the answer to
that I I don't know if there are I think
that in it as the the question mentions
I lose to that convergence has has been
evaluated I would say more in b-cell
receptor repertoires and that's owing in
part to the fact that somatic
hypermutation can create very strong
signatures of convergence so I would say
that from historical perspective there's
been more focused on the b-cell
repertoire for convergence but as we've
noted today I think it's also a feature
that that researchers should look into
for 40 tell repertoire analysis
so are not our next question is it's
number 10 and it says without dual
barcoding
how big of a problem is um of bleeding
yeah you know it's it to my
understanding from the data that I've
looked at it's actually quite not not a
big problem at all
it's our really our goal with the ion
dual is to strive towards continually
improving our product and a part of the
reason is that the s5 uses emulsion PCR
based templating so when when one
amplifies the template molecules and
makes copies of them on to bead this
occurs within an emulsion bubble and
that emulsion bubble acts as a physical
barrier that helps prevents the type of
barcode bleed through or index hopping
that that others have observed in the
literature so in general given that we
use emulsion TCR that's that's an aspect
that reduces the free overall reduces
the tendency towards barcode bleed
through
now dr. Looney will molecular tags
eliminate all sequencing errors
yeah you know that that's a great
question and you know what you know one
one logical question to ask given that
substitution sequencing errors may be
critical how much of those can be
eliminated through the use of molecular
tags and the truth is that molecular
tags can in some cases reduce errors but
they cannot eliminate all errors because
or they're not likely to because the the
molecular tags themselves are subject to
PCR and sequencing errors so there's
still some fundamental limit imposed by
the the library preparation and the
sequencing system that that is very
challenging to overcome and this is why
it's it's arguably best to avoid the
issue of substitution sequencing errors
by choosing the platform with most
substitution errors to begin with
now our next question is a is a two-part
question is it possible to compare data
generated by the LR and SR essays for
example using the LRS a to sequence
peripheral blood and the sr to
interrogate SF PE preserved tumor from
the same individual
yes yes you can do that and in fact the
iron reporter software is designed for
that very thing so one can certainly
evaluate clonal overlap and track clones
using both assays and into the the use
case the the the user brought up is is
really I think a common and good good
choice of the essays to enable the
getting the most out of your data
you
early in your presentation biological
replicates seek sequential biopsies
showed a great difference in T CRB
sequences how does a technical replicate
save cDNA would look
great question yeah technical replicates
as opposed to replicates like that I
showed and I think the slides
highlighted right now technical
replicates so resequencing of the same
library will show very high coronal
overlap greater than greater than 90
percent of clones will be shared now
repertoire sequencing is one of those
things where the input material can be
incredibly diverse and so only some of
that diversity is captured in a single
library particularly when you're using a
small amount of that input material to
prepare a library so that for this
reason one does not expect to detect
very high clonal overlap in when
preparing libraries from the same pool
of RNA derived from polyclonal t-cell
the teeth of polyclonal t-cell
population
you
now it looks like our next question is
do customers have access to the raw data
yes yes that's that's we provide access
to all of the raw data and you know I
think that's a great way for for those
out there to perform their own
experiments and develop their own
algorithms if they'd like and I think
that's desert that's a great aspect of
the system that we developed
and it looks like we have time for one
more question have you evaluated TCR
convergence and autoimmune diseases such
as rheumatoid arthritis
No you know what we haven't yet but
that's that's a great question and you
know rheumatoid arthritis it's one of
those conditions where there's thought
to be an important role for a buret post
translational modification particularly
Stitch elimination and one could
hypothesize that convergence values may
be elevated in individuals with
rheumatoid arthritis and given that that
aspect of the disease and the fact that
there is a need for predictive
biomarkers I think that that's that's a
great question that's a it could be a
good use case for the study of
convergence
thank you again dr. Looney do you have
any final comments for our audience I'd
like to thank them for taking the time
to listen and I really enjoyed
presenting our work and I and I wish you
the best of luck in your research
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of the registration
if you happen to miss any of our
three-part immuno oncology series at the
end of this webinar you will be
redirected to the registration page for
our first for our first webinar where
you can watch dr. Simon Colley highlight
recent advancements driven by
next-generation sequencing that may lead
to a deeper understanding of the cancer
immunity cycle on that page you will
also find a link to the first part of
today's presentation where dr. Lemmy
describes the advantages of loan
amplicon TCR be sequencing via ion
torrent for me no therapy biomarker
discovery from peripheral blood
thank you dr. Looney for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank laberd's and our
sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through March of 2019 leverets will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with their colleagues who may
have missed today's live of it until
next time goodbye
you